You're so big!
Hello!
Welcome!
Welcome to Vade Retro!
Yay!
Why don't we have some new friends here?
Why don't you guys introduce yourselves?
Okay, not it.
Not me.
I'll go first.
Fuck you, I'll go first.
Pushes everybody out of the way.
Hi!
I'm KaiSekota from Idle.
Gen 2.
I'm a dragon.
It's pretty cool.
Hi!
Alright, cool.
That's it.
That's all I got.
Wow.
Thank you, blushes.
Hello!
My name is Bree!
I'm not from Idle.
I'm just me.
I'm a bunny.
I like Elden Ring.
I play a lot of that game.
That's it.
That's my entire personality.
We got a fucking name in the house!
Thank you for clarifying that you were not from Idle.
I was actually really confused.
I was like, I can't believe you're from my company.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Well, okay.
In my defense, in my head, you were gonna go, like, Yuna was gonna go after Kai, and then I was gonna be like, oh my god, I'm not an Idle.
And then you were like, Bree, go!
My rehearsal in my head didn't make sense.
Keep your enemies under toes.
I'm Annex.
I'm Puta Stern.
I'm Puta.
Hello, I'm Puta Juna Unagi from Idle EN's first generation.
I'm Kai.
I'm a EO bitch.
Nice.
That's really sweet.
That's better than me.
And I'm Doki Bird.
I think that's a good enough intro, I think.
I'm short and thin enough.
It's great.
I'm an Indie.
You're also not an Idle!
See you in Mixed-Up!
Who would've thought?
These guys, these guys, oh my gosh.
These guys, they came in here in this call like an hour before the stream started.
I was so not used to it.
I was like, looking at my Discord.
Because we have a Discord group for this collab.
And they were like, guys, are you guys, were you gonna call now before the collab?
And I was like, what?
So we can set it up and everything.
And I was like, whoa.
Yeah, because you gotta come in early so you can set everything up.
And then they're like, fuck, you have time to go.
By the way, you guys, I'm going to go.
I showed up 10 minutes.
I showed up 10 minutes before the stream started.
All these girls were in the call for an hour to 30 minutes.
And I was like, alright guys, I'm gonna be here in like 5-10 minutes, guys.
Kai, Rie, and I were just like shitting our pants like, oh my god, I can't believe Doki's fucking dead.
I'm just gonna pass out.
It's been 30 minutes.
We have 30 minutes.
It's okay.
Yeah.
I was like, I wonder if she's sleeping.
Yeah, I was.
I actually was.
I was napping.
I was napping like napping for like 1 or 2 hours and I woke up like 30 minutes before the stream started and I was like, yay.
Oh, we don't need an hour.
And then we were actually calculating it and they were like, no, no, because she put her waiting room today.
Like, she's up, right?
Like, she's not sleeping.
And I'm like, I don't know, guys.
It could be scheduled.
I was so not used to this.
I was like, you guys fucking got ready to get in an hour before.
I'm so used to people showing up 10 minutes before the collab started.
I was like...
Kai and I were hanging out before the call so we were just, we just moved over to the...
And I came in and I was like, did you guys do the tutorial?
And they're like, no.
And I was like, oh, okay.
I was like, alright, so you guys, what were you guys prepping?
Listen, we're prepared, but not that prepared.
We're just prepping the vibes.
You know, we're just prepping.
I didn't do the tutorial.
I have an excuse for not doing the tutorial.
I showed up 10 minutes before the stream.
Well, should we get started and see how, like, shit our mics are in-game?
Oh, yeah.
By the way, there's, like, in-game mic.
So, like, my audio guy, my audio guy was like, everybody's balanced.
I was like, yeah, for now, but we're gonna be using in-game mic later.
So you gotta figure that stuff out soon.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
Yep, I'm ready.
So, for those who don't know what this game is about, this is basically, apparently, for the people who tested this game an hour early, they told me it was, like, Dead by Daylight and Among Us mixed together.
So there's only one person who's a demon that's gonna kill all of us.
And I was the one that suggested the game because I saw there was a priest, and that was the only character I wanted to play.
So I was like, Kai was the priest when I got in the waiting room.
I was like, get the fuck off the priest.
I'm only playing this game.
For the priest.
Get the fuck off it.
I got bullied!
I'm literally getting bullied!
I literally don't know what to say.
Please get off priest.
I've been looking for... No, I was like, GET OFF FUCKING PRIEST!
You were an invited guest!
Yeah, you're right.
I'm playing engineering.
I don't know why you would leave the tech stuff to me.
It's okay.
I believe...
I don't.
For the priest, I looked at the controls because I was nervous.
So I got...
I was sitting up at like 3 o'clock in the afternoon.
I was so ready.
It's 7 now.
Oh my god.
You guys are so prepared.
I'm so prepped.
I've never done this before in my life.
I've never had a...
I have not had a collapsed starting time in a long ass time.
I remember when it was like, you know, the designated time to start the stream.
They were like, Oh my god, guys, it's time to start the stream.
I looked at the time.
It was like 4pm.
I was like, what?
Not 4.10?
Or 4.15?
We're at the starting at 4 exactly?
Oh my god.
We're spoiling you.
No, no.
It's okay.
I like the numbers.
You're real.
Please understand.
I was not ready for this.
Are we all ready to go in?
Yeah.
Wait.
Are we meeting everyone?
How do we start it?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Go away.
I'm gonna meet you guys.
Okay, bye.
Alright.
Here we go.
Whoa.
Press...
Hello?
I hear you.
Hello!
Oh my god.
You're the priest.
I'm the priest.
Okay, we gotta get... We have prep time.
It's like Batman.
We have prep time.
Okay, there's a shockwave.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe we should have done the tutorial.
What are all of these?
Oh my god.
I have stats?
I can adjust my skills?
Oh no.
Right click.
Oh, I want the dove.
I want the power of the dove.
We don't have enough XP.
Oh no.
What did I grab?
Orbs.
That spin around you and weaken the... Okay, I got the orb.
I can only pick one.
Why do you have just these... You have a dove.
You have a... I have... I have the orb.
I have the orb.
Don't worry.
I have... I have the orb.
What the fuck?
How did you mute yourself?
Alright, here we go.
I don't know.
I can't... Alright, it's time to...
It's time to kill Juna.
We never liked her in the first place.
Right?
You would meet both of us.
Here, I'll take pictures of the dead body.
That's looking right.
I just met... Okay, that's not a lie.
I didn't just meet her.
I met her at a convention.
I meet and greet.
But like...
But like, I heard...
Like, I was her oshi and I thought this would be the perfect time to kill her.
To say, never meet your heroes.
It would be such a great time.
Never meet your heroes.
I don't know what I'm saying.
She's gonna learn the hard way.
Alright.
Wait, we do have objectives then.
We have?
Oh shit, I was not...
Okay, find a crochet tool.
I need a crochet.
Unlock the armor door.
Fight evil spirits.
Woah!
Who the fuck is she?
Is that you, Juna?
Who is she?
No, I think it's an NPC.
There's NPCs?
Yeah, there's NPCs of...
The guy can disguise as NPCs and then eat other NPCs.
Wait, what the fuck is her mission?
But I don't know if Juna knows that she can do that.
Oh, she doesn't.
She didn't do the tutorial.
You were the only one that did the tutorial, so it's fine.
I'm prepared!
We have the only person that's...
Wait, hello?
Hey, lady.
Oh, there's meds!
Wait, there's meds.
Yeah, yeah.
I got the bandage.
I don't know how to use it, but I got the bandages.
Neither do I.
Oh, I can lock the doors too.
I can try demon beam.
Okay.
Wait, what's this?
Hiding...
Exorcist can hide and beware the...
Oh!
Oh, you don't see me.
I need my protection device.
Guys!
Juna's right here!
On my door!
She's soft!
That's Juna!
That's her!
Be gone!
Oh!
You're stunning all of us!
Oh, did I stun you?
I don't know.
No, I think I did.
Oh, oh, wait.
Is Kyle... Okay.
Okay, you... Sorry, I'm good.
Sorry.
Alright, we're fine.
Yeah, okay.
Juna's gone.
Okay, I know what she looks like now, though.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I have this.
I found the crochet tool!
I found it!
Yeah, we gotta unlock the armor door with the pick tool.
Who has the pick tool?
Oh, wait.
Is the crochet...
Is the crochet tool the pick tool?
Oh, maybe that is.
Yeah.
Where the fuck is the door?
Guys, I think...
Guys, I have a feeling that maybe we should have done the tutorial.
Yeah, maybe.
I think we should have done the tutorial.
I need the tutorial and I'm lost.
Okay.
So, I don't know.
We'll be fine.
Because I'm like... I have so many...
I have so many...
I have so many items.
But I'm trying to figure out how to pull up my...
Oh, I...
Oh, if you press tab, you can pull up your items.
Oh, yeah.
I healed myself.
She's got pills.
That's it.
I don't think Juna knows what she's doing.
Nope.
I don't know.
Let me bring up my game volume a little bit.
Ooh.
Okay, I brought up my game volume.
You know, I thought this would be a lot scarier, but it's kind of not that bad.
It's not that bad.
I think it's also because we're grouped up together.
I don't know.
I saw...
I just got a tutorial on how to hide in a closet.
So, like...
I don't know if I should do that.
We need to find...
I think it's also easier right now because we're together.
So, we're not as close together.
I'm scared.
I think Juna does not know where the fuck we are.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Yeah, dude.
I think she's equally as lost.
Wait, no.
It's this.
Demon gets closer.
Wait, no.
I think she might be nearby.
Whoa.
Oh, I can't.
No, she's not.
Is she close?
Is she still close by?
Oh, I got no clue.
I have no idea what she looks like.
I kind of want her to...
What the fuck?
What's that?
Is that Juna?
Is that you?
I threw it.
Yes, the anti-invisible potion.
She can't be invisible in here.
Because apparently she can be invisible.
Oh, wait.
There's a ladder here.
Whoa.
Guys.
I got a ladder.
Oh, it was...
I don't know what to do with it.
I just got the ladder.
Oh, there's more bandages.
Wait, wait, wait.
Bree.
Whoa.
Okay, she inked.
I got scared.
Okay.
It's just some old woman.
Okay, okay.
Take the bandage.
And like, heal.
Press tab and then click on the...
Click on your bandage.
Oh my god.
Am I injured?
Yes, you are.
Look at your HP.
What?
What do you mean, am I injured?
I didn't know.
Bro, Juna must be so funny.
I mean, she's fucking...
She looks good.
She is like so fucking confused.
I wonder if there's like...
Wait, wait, stand still.
I'm gonna use this gun on you.
Ow.
What?
Yes.
What the fuck?
I thought it was you.
Well, don't keep doing it.
Don't keep... I'm fucking healing myself right now.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
There you go.
Well, you had a little bit left, so I was like, oh my god, I'm gonna hurt you.
Don't make me use this.
Wait, what?
Wait, she was next to us!
She was next to us!
What?
Was that her?
Yeah!
Yeah, we fought!
Oh my god!
Bro!
I can't believe it.
I wanted to hurt you guys, but then I'm right here.
Task failed successfully.
If only I had made this much of a wrench gun, it would have been great.
Oh my god.
We would go downstairs for it.
We have to find some armor door shit.
Where's the armor door?
My gamer senses was tingling.
Oh, don't worry.
Watch this.
Demon is getting closer.
We're okay.
She's not close enough.
Whoa, this is spooky.
Where's the power?
What the fuck?
Did you ink again?
Okay.
I was gonna say, did you ink again?
I'm sorry.
You can't just keep throwing those at everyone.
I can't.
Wait, you have unlimited?
Actual menace.
You have unlimited?
There's like a regen.
Oh yeah, me too.
I do too.
Invincibility.
What is that?
That has to be an NPC, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, cause I hit him with my anti-demonic beam.
Yeah, I don't think that's an NPC.
Yeah, that's not her.
That's an NPC right here.
Oh my god, where the fuck...
Stop shooting me with the surprise!
AHHHHH!
RECOUN!
Oh, that's him.
That's him.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I can't see.
Oh, F, F, F, press F.
Flashlight.
Okay, here we go.
I'm doing it.
Where's the circuit breaker?
I did it!
The circuit breaker.
Okay, alright, alright.
It's okay, Chiwo is gone.
I fucking...
Suck it!
Suck it, dude!
I said be gone and she disappeared.
Oh my god.
Guys!
One of you guys must have played this game.
In my chat.
Where's the...
We must have one person that plays this game.
Please!
I'm so lost.
You have exercised a demon, right?
I should not be leading anybody in this game.
I don't know where anything is.
I wanna go outside!
Oh my god!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, this thing, they heal at this thing.
This is the thing that when we enter them, she has to go back here.
Tutorial!
Yippee!
I think that just leads out to...
Someone said... I just realized...
I have a syringe and I have a syringe gun.
And I was using the syringe gun on you.
Oh my fucking... Heal me!
Stop!
Oh my god, please!
You're not healing!
No, you're not!
What are you doing?
Alright, let's make sure that no one's near us while you do this.
Okay, here...
I did say she was getting closer.
What the fuck did you do?
That did nothing.
Well, you have a shield now.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Oh...
Hey, I think she's close by.
I see like...
Be gone!
Oh my god, I can't fucking see now.
I know!
It's the anti-invisibility, but also with the anti-sight.
Is this her?
Wait, that is her!
What the fuck?
Be gone!
Wait, no, that's not her!
That's an NPC!
This NPC was like, help!
This group of girls are gay and beating me up!
We fucking beat up an old man!
Oh no!
We beat up some...
She took damage!
What the fuck?
That was her!
Wait, are you okay?
Oh, she's not okay!
Get up!
I did that!
Yo, you can get up, don't be a little bitch!
I beat you up!
I'm gonna beat you up!
What are you doing?
Be gone!
I'll do it!
You're ugly as hell!
Be gone!
Oh shit!
Bro, she's beating us up!
Bro!
This sucks!
Why can't we, like...
I think she's like, they possessed him.
Oh shit!
I think it's cause like...
She's taking damage.
You can see on her HP that she's taking damage.
Don't worry, I'm getting coming over!
You can't hide from us!
Drewna, we're gonna kill you!
Get over here!
I have more spells!
Look at her run!
She's right here in front of me!
Be gone!
Get over here!
Bro!
She's fucked up!
Oh, she disappeared!
She went invisible!
Wait, I have a thing for this!
She's gone!
What a little bitch!
This is such a bad end line!
Okay, I'll save her.
Don't worry, God is in you.
Don't worry.
I saved her.
Yay!
Get up, stupid!
Don't worry, not believe in God.
I'm a fucking loser.
Wait, I see her!
She's like right here!
Drewna, I see you!
Yes!
Where did she go?
I saw her fucking...
I don't know.
I like how we gave up on the armored door.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, can I heal you?
God, you're healed!
Please, actually use your syringe.
I don't!
Please!
Use your syringe!
Wait!
Bro, are you kidding me?
She's losing HP!
What are you doing?
I think I know what to do!
I'd rather have Drewna kill me at this point.
Oh, I see her.
I see her.
She's right here outside this door.
She's right here.
Oh, there she's coming!
She's coming!
Oh, no!
Bro, are you a medic?
Where did you get your fucking degree?
You can't...
You literally...
You literally have one job!
Your one job is to heal us!
But I can choke some birds!
What the fuck?
She's not being healed!
She lost half of HP because you shot her!
I thought everyone was certified at the same time!
Oh, my God.
Okay, look.
As someone that's not a priest, here's to take these pills and heal yourself.
I wasted all my pills on myself as well.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I have three.
How do I...
You just left-click it.
What are you doing?
These pills aren't for you!
Nope!
You're the one that needs HP!
I can take some too!
Look, I'm better now!
Please.
What are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
I'm trying to figure out...
Guys, take the HP!
Three.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to heal you!
Three, for the love of God!
Ask your chat how to play your character for the love of God!
For the love of God!
I'm just putting the word sad in the chat!
Can you hold?
Just hold the needle!
Oh, my God.
Wait.
That's a good idea.
Have you not been holding?
Oh, my God.
I have a gun!
Holy shit.
Stop!
We have limited heals!
How is Juna taking damage?
None of us are doing anything!
She lost half...
She lost one third of her HP!
She lost so much!
Holy shit.
Okay.
What do you mean, it won't?
What do you mean?
You haven't done anything!
My game volume so far...
That was the game volume so far, guys.
We have... where is the armory door?
Yeah, no.
I'm trying to find it too, but I don't see anything.
Like I just don't know...
Oh, wait.
Well, I think maybe...
...do you think it's in the basement?
Oh, yeah.
It could be.
It's always in the basement.
Oh, my God.
Where is it?
Oh, dude, holy shit.
You're so smart.
Oh my god.
Wait, Tara, I found it!
I found it!
Wait, I think so?
I'm right here, follow my boys!
Guys, I don't think Juna knows there's a basement.
We're so, we're so, we're so okay.
Okay, there's hope.
There's no way she knows there's a basement.
Wait, wait, wait, we have to go back down.
That's the outside.
Okay.
No, no, there has to be an armored door.
Wait, what's this?
I found it!
How the f- Oh, I found it!
Guys, guys, I'm a priest.
I don't know how to do lockpicking.
How the fuck?
How the?
What?
Oh, I did it!
How the?
What?
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
I don't know what I did!
Oh my god, there's- Oh my god, there's evil- Oh my god, turn around, there's a thing here!
Oh my god!
Begone!
Ow, I'm taking damage!
How do I?
Begone!
Oh my god, I took so much damage.
Wait, wait, wait, go, go, go, wait, wait.
Go in!
Begone!
BEGONE!
Guys, I'm not doing anything.
Guys, I'm not doing anything in this room.
I...
Oh, I'm doing it!
I'm doing it!
I'm saying stuff in my book!
I stopped saying things in my book, guys.
Oh, wait, are you?
Oh, okay.
Wait, one of them is gone!
Wait, I think you were doing... I think it was your job!
I think it was your job!
Yeah, you fucking zapped!
You like, ghost busted that shit!
Yeah, I'm not doing anything, guys.
Yeah, yeah, you were ghost busting.
Yeah, it was you!
Oh my god, it was you!
That was your job!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I have bandages.
Okay, the priest has bandages!
Guys, get over here!
What are you doing here, Juna?
Leave, Juna!
We're doing our thing!
Guys!
Guys, guys, come over here!
I have bandages!
Guys!
Guys, get over here!
I have bandages!
I have bandages right here!
Yeah, yeah, let me push up the game then.
I have...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, let me...
Feel it.
Alright, heal so you can get rid of the last guy.
We need you to get rid of the last ghost!
Literally, that's all we have to do.
Get fucked!
You're good.
Yeah, I'll just exist here.
I'll just get rid of JUNA for you.
Get away from us, Juna!
Get away!
Go away!
We're doing our job!
What are you doing, Juna?
What the fuck?
There she is!
I think I got them!
Oh, shoot!
Yeah!
Demonic Altar's been destroyed!
We did it!
Yeah, yeah!
We have more?
You know, I'm just...
Lighting!
Oh my god!
Oh, wait, wait!
I have matches!
We can... I can... We just need to find the altar.
Yeah!
Wait, me too!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just gotta go find the altar.
Where that is.
Yeah, find the altars.
I feel like we saw the altars on the second floor.
I'm shielding you.
Okay, I feel like...
Having a medic is like, useless.
What the fuck?
Oh, my medic doesn't shoot us.
I'm just trying to assist!
I just saw the button!
I'm doing something!
What the fuck?!
No, you're not!
You are not doing anything!
What the fuck?!
Be good!
Oh, no!
Oh, my God!
You are definitely not doing anything!
Let me save this...
Believe in God!
I don't know, I feel like...
I feel like they give us...
Why?
I don't know.
What?
No morals!
I need a benefit!
Woah.
Oh, he's just...
Bro, that's not...
He's just a normal guy.
He's just a nor...
Yeah, man.
What the...
What?
Fuck.
The demon took its final form... for one minute!
Hide!
Shh!
Where's the closet?
Oh no.
I don't know...
Guys, I think we'll be okay guys.
Can you hear me?
There's no way, right?
There's...
That they can hear me.
Right, guys?
We'll be okay.
Shhhh.
The team is no longer invincible!
We're okay!
Guys!
He's no longer invincible!
Guys?
Wait, I think Kai's dead.
Guys, I think Kai's dead.
Hello?
You did your job!
You actually did your job!
I don't know where you are, but I can see Kai is not dead anymore.
Did you figure out how to be a medic now?
Did you finally figure it out?
Apparently, I can only be a medic if you're dead.
Alright, now we know.
It's okay!
She's not invincible!
Okay, okay.
Don't worry.
She's literally 1 HP.
You cannot shoot her anymore.
You actually can't shoot her anymore.
She's literally 1 HP right now.
You cannot do that.
We gotta find...
I feel like we've seen the altar before.
Okay, I'm gonna lock... I'm gonna start locking doors.
Wait, there's a meds!
There's meds!
Take the meds!
Wait, I think... I think I remember there being like a... It was like a room.
It was like downstairs and it was like a table in the middle of the floor and that was it.
Yeah, yeah, that has to be!
Why would there be a table in the middle of the floor?
That has to be!
Alright, let's see.
I'm gone.
Just in case.
I gotta be sure.
Are you sure?
Okay, look.
I'm not feeling so confident.
She's like the our only lead right now, so...
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Okay, okay.
I think it's my job.
Okay, wait, wait.
Whose job is this?
Is this my job?
How do I light it?
Light the... I locked the door.
I locked the door so she can't get in.
I don't think.
How do we do this?
We should be fine, but...
Whose job is this?
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't know.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is the ritual table.
It's placed the parchment on the ritual table.
Oh, that's the ritual.
Okay, this is not a...
I take back the celebratory gunshot.
Okay, that's not the...
We know where it is though.
Okay, we know where it is.
Okay, someone marked... Okay, remember this, Bri.
You gotta remember this.
You're literally our only hope.
I'm genuinely awful with directions.
I get lost in strings always.
Okay, that's terrible because so am I.
Okay, so...
This is bad.
Wait, what's this?
Is this?
We found it!
We got it!
This is what we look like.
This is what they look like.
Okay, they're basically a table.
We know what they look like now.
And there was like a flag on it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We know what they look like now.
Oh, the range was not far enough.
Sorry.
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna cool down.
Oh, you're gonna protect Kai.
Okay.
Kai is a whole centimeter from death.
Be gone!
Okay, he's not here.
She's not here.
Okay, she's not here.
Oh, goodbye, Kai.
Oh, goodbye.
She just punches me to death.
Wait.
Be gone!
This is unfair.
Like, I wanna fight back.
I think I'm the only one that can fight back.
I'm pretty sure.
You're actually higher HP now.
I have a few, like, buffing or, like, debuff.
I can slow her down.
And then my gunshot is apparently good against her.
I'm pretty sure, like, the engineer is, like, the one that actually does all the exorcism stuff.
And I'm just here to fight the demon.
Be gone!
Get embarrassed.
Yeah.
Did you just take a photo?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I found it!
I found the altar!
I found one!
We just need one more!
Show it to her later.
She'll cry.
We just need one more!
Whoa!
What does that mean?
What, what, what, what?
What?
There's a sound?
I heard, like, a thunk.
I didn't hear anything.
I don't know.
I think you're a fucking paranoid right now.
We literally just need one more.
Where the fuck is the last altar?
It has to be on this floor.
Dude...
Who the fuck was that?
I know God.
Be gone!
Is she... Is she gone now?
Oh, she's gone.
Guys, we're back here.
Okay, she is not a coward.
She was not a coward.
Boom!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Watch this, watch this, watch this.
Come on.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh, my God!
Get around!
Oh, my God, what is she doing?
What?
How could you do that?
I'll fucking stab you!
She's going after me.
She gave you a freebie, bro.
Bro, that was like a fucking strip club or something.
We were like at a bachelor party and we hired Juna to have...
We were like, hey, yeah...
She was like...
She was like straddling your waist.
Yeah.
And then I felt like we were at a bachelor party and we're like giving you a nice like birthday party.
One last day before your hitch, bro.
Juna would.
Juna would, honestly.
On my end, it literally just looks like she's beating the shit out of me.
I'm trying so hard.
I'm trying so hard to heal you.
Oh my god.
Okay, we need one more.
There has to be the last fucking alter.
We probably like ran around it like a million times.
We probably have.
I found one of them.
Should we?
I hate to say it.
Should we split up?
Okay, how about like since you're...
Should we?
No!
That's what they say in every freaking horror movie ever.
Okay, Bri should stick with Kai because Kai's the most fucked up right now.
I'll just heal you.
Okay, I don't have healers.
Okay.
Okay, if I...
I thought she was gonna say something.
Don't worry.
I'll split up with you guys and you two find the last alter.
Alright, you guys ready?
I'm the only one...
I believe in you.
Okay.
Alright, I'm going this way.
Just start screaming.
Yeah, don't worry.
Okay.
I believe in you guys.
Don't go, Kai.
Come on.
I'm gonna see if there's an alter at the top floor.
Oh, well, come again.
Alright, we'll go this way.
Yeah, you guys look at the bottom floor.
Face it.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Okay.
Just keep talking because I can still hear you guys on the second floor.
Okay, I can't hear them anymore on the second floor.
I guess that was not true.
Guys, I can't hear them anymore.
Guys, I sadly cannot hear them.
I know what their HP is like.
Oh my god.
Brie is almost...
Can Brie heal herself?
Brie can...
We did it!
Oh my god!
It literally spawned next to me!
Guys!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna lock the door!
Guys!
Are you guys alive?
Guys, guys, guys!
I found the parchment!
Guys!
I don't know where it is.
I'm downstairs!
Downstairs!
Guys!
Oh!
I found the parchment!
It literally spawned next to me when you guys found the altar!
Oh, nice!
Okay, we gotta go to the other place!
Okay, Brie, Brie, Brie, where is it?
Where is it?
Where is the thing?
We gotta go this way and then dining room table.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then...
I don't...
Uh...
You don't know where you're going, do you?
No, this way?
No, I have confidence.
No, no, no, no.
I always go this way.
This way.
And then this way.
Because we're back in the main lobby.
Oh my god, we're so good at this game.
There we go.
Trina must have been so fucking confused.
Be gone, demon!
You have lost four...
A demonic altar has been destroyed.
Wait, I can...
Oh my god, I forgot.
Wait, I can heal.
Are your teammates two times faster during agony?
Observation!
What the fuck?
Wait, I can heal.
I can heal.
Remember to recharge your observation...
We don't need full skills to heal.
Holy sh...
Yeah!
I'm going to be like, wait, we could have been like, working on upgrading ourselves.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh no...
Okay.
You need to do this one first.
I max out on attack.
I'm going to...
Oh my god, there are so many.
Okay.
Defense.
I'm going to put...
You, like, attack.
How do I...
Like, appearing attack...
Recharge your heal mana?
How do I heal?
I don't know!
What do you mean, recharge my heal...
My healing mana...
Oh, man!
I know, I think she's outside.
I think she's outside.
I think she is.
Wait, maybe if I like...
Alright, here we go, let's see.
Oh, she left.
Okay, she left.
Okay, I swear to god she was out.
Oh my god, I'm getting so used to this.
I'm helping her!
I feel like...
Oh my god, putting it more on... I'm gonna put it on defense.
Fuck this.
Alright, we got by.
She's climbing the fucking...
She must be like, why can't I kill them?
Oh my god.
Are you just hiding?
Oh, the breaker!
Eddie, do your job!
Oh my god, she chucked it at me!
God, she's fucking getting closer!
Get away!
Be gone!
Okay, I think I got... Bree, Bree, we need you.
Bree, get out of the fucking closet!
We've been fucking fighting for our lives and she's still...
Bree, I swear...
I'm not sure if Yuna's going after... not going after me because I'm just not a threat.
I'm just not helpful at all.
Oh!
Wait, wait!
She's almost in!
Wait, I can kill her!
Oh, we got her!
We got her!
I got her!
We can actually kill her!
We got her on the run!
Where is she?
Oh hey, what's this?
Oh, that's one of the...
Oh, oh.
Wait for the wolves to enter the circle.
She's actually stumbling by the goal.
Wait, we have to like... we have to find the meat.
We gotta go get the meat.
Where the fuck is the freezer?
Okay.
It has to be up top, right?
I mean, I assume it's in the...
The kitchen, right?
I assume it's either in the basement or it's in the kitchen.
Yeah.
Did you just burn the bird?
Yeah, yeah.
Fuck that bird.
Did you just attack the bird?
Fuck the... What has that bird done for us?
I mean, the kitchen was up top.
My kitchen was over here.
Yeah, it was the second floor, right?
Oh, it was here?
No... Oh, no.
I don't know.
I feel like there has to be a kitchen on the second floor.
Yeah, I'm going to the top.
Come on.
Come on, guys.
It has to be on the second floor.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Uh...
Uh... Don't worry!
Be gone!
Okay.
Thank you.
All right, all right.
I participated.
All right.
Come on.
It has to be...
Oh, someone said it's on the first floor.
Someone said it's on the... Thank you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you for that one guy that actually played this game.
The one person that played this game.
No, not here.
No, no.
Don't tell me.
How many fucking laundry mats do they have?
Right?
Oh, no.
I'm lost.
Oh, how do I repair this?
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Why would... Okay, let's fucking do like house renovations too, by the way.
It's like con zombies.
Yeah.
Wait, what are you... Oh.
Wait, but what if we have to go through this later?
Oh, wait.
She's coming near again.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Well, who cares?
All right.
Who's going to win first?
I hope Juna can die like in this game.
Oh, I thought it was her.
Go away.
Okay.
She's here.
Go away.
Fuck off.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I'm so sick of her.
She's so ugly.
Holy shit.
She's ugly.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the...
Are you sure?
Okay.
Maybe that guy who said it's in the first floor was lying to us.
No, I'm not lying.
Because I swear...
I'm not lying.
I swear.
What a deceiver.
A liar.
Where is the kitchen?
Fucking.
She's in here.
Brie.
We need you.
Oh my God.
Brie has to split up from all of us.
The most important person in our team.
Brie.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I can save you.
I can save you.
Okay.
I saved him.
I saved her.
Okay.
This way.
We found him.
Oh, no.
Oh, Brie.
We got you a surprise!
It's here?
Where's the kitchen?
And then here, and then here.
Oh, they turned off the power again.
Oh, I found... Oh, hey!
I got all three!
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Don't worry.
Thank God!
I got it!
Go get the electricity!
Alright, alright.
Huge, huge, huge.
Alright, we got it.
We're so lagged.
We gotta go back.
We gotta go outside!
I zapped her a million times.
Oh, shit!
Guys!
No!
Please!
God would not forsaken me!
Bro, I'm like hanging by the thread right now.
I'm hanging by the thread.
We got it.
I'm gonna grab the wood.
I got wood.
Guys, gang!
We gotta get the wood!
We're carpenters now!
We are carpenters!
We gotta clean up!
It's okay.
I got three!
We need two more, guys!
We need two more!
Two more?
Two more wood.
I was hanging by the bird.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Can we just leave?
Wait, we gotta...
Place the wood around... I gotta get two more.
Just be like, sorry, this is just too much.
This is above our pay grade.
They're like, bro, aren't you enjoying your bachelor party, bro?
You won't be able to do this anymore when you get your wife!
I found another... Oh, nice.
Okay, we gotta find another ex.
Where's the other ex?
Oh, another ex?
Yeah.
Place the wood around the indicated...
Yeah, but we already have enough, though.
We already have enough.
Oh, whoa!
Oh, Bri did it!
Wait for wolves?
Where the fuck did Bri go?
Bri!
Where are you, Bri?
Oh, there they are!
Oh yeah!
There's some wolves!
Look!
There's the wolves!
What?
What help?
Oh, bitches!
Oh, she gone.
She's gone.
We did it, guys!
We're like, what do you need help?
We're fine.
Like,
what are you talking about?
We were maxed out stats!
Now what do we...
We're maxed out.
Is that it?
Did we do it?
Did we win?
Did we just kill her?
I guess we just kill her.
Demon's getting closer.
Demon's getting...
What?!
Don't worry, I got you.
That looks...
Oh my god.
I think we did it.
I think we're supposed to kill her now.
We're finally not 1 HP.
Alright.
Come on, Judah!
We're maxed out now!
Come over here and kill us!
Literally!
We did everything!
You won't!
Come on, Judah!
We're literally out in the open!
I shot her every time!
It's time.
Someone in my chat said that she can't heal anymore, is what we did.
So she's just like at that HP and she can't go higher.
Okay.
Oh, that's right.
Judah, this is it.
1v3 us right now.
Come on!
Get over here!
I'm gonna have a Mexican stand-off.
1v3!
I'm like fucking hanging by the thread right now.
I'm hanging by the thread.
1v3.
I got this!
Judah, if anything, just slap me first.
Judah, just slap me first so I can get revived and have back my HP.
Judah, that's fucking right!
Be gone!
Shit!
Okay, she slapped me, guys!
Guys, she slapped me!
Okay, nice.
Thank God.
Alright.
We did it.
I'm okay.
Oh, wait!
There she is!
Wait!
Her footsteps!
Wait, where?
Wait, I can see her footsteps.
Yeah, but it disappeared.
Oh!
Judah, get down!
You know it's over, Judah!
Back here!
Judah, it's over!
Right here!
Wait, what?
I lost her.
Wait, guys!
Wait, we split up!
That's not how we're supposed to do this!
Get back here!
Where is she?
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh my God!
Guys, we got Cressy!
Cressy!
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh shit, wait!
Just fucking... Hello?
Huge hello!
I just... I like how it just kicks us out of the game!
It really kicked... Wait, it kicked you out?
Yeah, it kicked me out!
It kicked me out!
What the hell?
I'm solid!
Oh my God!
It's the same lobby?
Yeah, same lobby.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
You know the name and power.
Okay.
How was it, Judah, beating the demon?
Yeah, what is it?
I was like, bro, like, how do I do the abilities?
And they're like, oh, you have to press, like, the F1, F2.
And I was like, oh.
But then I realized it was a fucking scroll wheel, like, at the end of the fucking game.
So the reason why I would just, like, stop and stand in front of you guys is because, like, okay, I have to press F6 now.
No!
Oh my God.
Bro, why do you... you guys want to die?
It's because I was killing them.
I did my job.
You killed two and then you're still fucking alive!
You're not killing!
What the fuck do you mean?
Nothing!
Oh my God, I can't believe you guys are inting in my race.
What is it?
What the fuck is it?
Vade retro...
Yeah, there you go!
I can't fucking... I can't believe this.
I can't believe you're inting in my high elo Vade.
I don't know.
It just sounds like somebody who's just got skill diffed.
No!
But it was funny in the beginning.
V was like, oh, I read the instructions, like, she could kill NPCs, but she doesn't know that I was standing in the same room as you guys.
What?
I can hear you guys.
God damn it.
I can't believe you guys are inting in my race.
What is that?
You couldn't hear us!
The visibility potion works.
I was standing everywhere.
You know, because I was at the closet at some point.
I'm like, I wonder if I have to be quiet.
I wonder if she can hear me.
And I heard you just like, I'm in the closet.
Not the first time though.
And I was like, oh.
Oh my God, this puta.
I can't believe you can actually hear us.
That just makes it so much better.
Who's gonna be the demon now?
Not it.
Wait, actually.
I'll do it.
All right.
Okay.
I'll swap roles.
He wants to be the priest now.
I tried to kill, like, I tried to like hit the rest of you guys, but Kai just kept like coming in front of me.
I was like, bitch.
What are you doing, dude?
Holy shit.
Uh huh.
Oh my God.
You want me so bad.
Like, dude.
You're like, puta, I'm sick and tired of you.
I was like, yeah.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
But why do you keep coming back to me?
Okay, Juna, I hope you actually heal.
It says you have the ability to heal your teammates quickly.
Drop healing kits or spawn devices that can increase the life of exorcists.
Yeah.
I'm a little silly.
Wait, wait, wait.
Someone said that in my chat literally immediately as the game ended.
They're like, no, no, no, breathe.
That's not good.
The syringe doesn't heal.
It's just melee damage.
Like, I didn't know.
Oh
my God.
Wait, Doki, do you want priest or...
I'll be the engineer.
Okay.
Now she's engineer.
What can I do actually?
Technology is your friend.
Install cameras, use various sensors and weaken the demon with advanced tool.
I didn't even know I could do that.
So advanced tool.
Okay.
That's a lot of stuff that somebody not did.
I don't think I've seen any of these things in that game we play.
Oh, I don't know.
Okay.
I'm muting.
I started my bad.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, muting, muting.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh my God.
Look at all these tools.
Anti-demonic beam.
I'm gonna grab...
I already have this spell.
There's an electric blower.
Drive the demon away.
I got a car.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
I need 200 XP.
Magnet.
Detects useful when the demons become...
Oh my God.
I can grab so many items.
You can grab so many items, guys.
Just spam grab them.
Oh my God.
Oh, you just...
Oh, okay, okay.
So, you just grab all of them?
Okay.
Yeah, you can grab multiple ones.
Just spam clicking.
Okay.
I swear to God.
You're gonna grab a heal.
I did it.
No.
There's one job.
I have seven items.
I didn't even read what they are.
I just kept grabbing.
Yeah.
I have seven items.
Oh wait no!
I have seven items too!
Yeah, I just kept grabbing!
Oh so maybe you didn't grab them.
Okay.
Gamer's don't look up!
Surveillance camera.
Oh!
What the hell?
There you go.
Yeah, no the monster had the... the monster had push to talk so I just like...
unpushed to talk myself.
Alright, let's see.
Oh wait, really?
I'm gonna try and put...
Guys, do you think the demon's gonna go through this?
Hello!
Guys, I... I don't... I fucked it up.
Wait, the demon's already closed though.
I don't want you telling me I'm ugly when you were looking like you did before.
Oh my god.
I don't want you talking to me when you were looking that way.
I couldn't find a fucking NPC and I had to pick an ugly old man.
You look ugly.
Wait, I wanna be a...
Holy shit.
I gotta go to the spa.
You gotta get your nails...
I gotta put a...
I got a cam...
What the fuck?
Wait, what was that?
I heard a slam.
Oh.
What the fuck?
I got a car.
Look.
Look at this car.
Oh my god, that's so funny.
Guys, I like how nobody's protecting me while I'm in this car.
Let me just be in this corner.
Nobody's...
Wait, I think I got it.
Okay.
Wait, is that a demon?
Oh, he...
That watch!
He just walked in once!
That's her, guys!
That's her!
I can't see anything.
Yeah!
That's her!
She's just looking at us!
Be gone!
Yeah!
Oh my Jesus!
It's okay, guys.
I got us.
Where is she?
Wait, where is she?
She's gone.
I got us.
Wait, where is she?
Oh, my bad.
I got us.
My bad.
Okay, we did a bit of damage.
I got like...
Just stood there.
I just...
Oh, does that heal you guys?
She was just standing there.
She's like, I don't know what I'm doing.
I can't help you.
Oh, that's a shield.
Okay, we got a fire...
Whoa!
Lights!
Where the lights are?
The circuit breakers.
Okay, okay.
Where are the circuit breakers?
Don't worry.
Are you fixing it?
Found one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The priest is doing it.
The priest went to electrician school.
Before he became a priest, he went to trade school.
And then he found God.
What did he learn at trade school?
He found God after.
Found God.
Yeah.
But...
I have like cameras.
But I don't think I'm gonna use them.
I don't think I'm gonna use the camera.
Don't worry.
I got it.
I have no idea what the camera does.
I was trying.
I have no clue.
Don't worry.
I have movement too.
I don't even think I picked up half of the stuff.
Oh my God.
Demon gets closer.
Don't worry.
I have a metal detector.
Like, can I shoot the innocent people?
Oh my God.
He's on me.
She's on me.
Oh my God.
What the...
Please.
This is the thing.
Oh my God.
Please.
Why is my priest not doing anything?
Why?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
What?
I'm trying to fucking leave the camera.
What the fuck?
I can't figure out how to do it.
Oh, there she is.
She's right there.
There she is.
Oh my God.
Get her out.
Get extra sister out.
Get out of here.
Get out.
Get that shit.
Oh my God.
She's right there.
What the fuck?
She's...
I cannot see.
Holy fuck.
Guys, we have to like...
I can't see a fucking thing.
Guys, we have to fucking...
Grab the electric...
I think Rhea actually knows how to play this game.
That's crazy.
Wait.
Is that you?
What is...
What are you doing?
Oh, guys.
Guys.
She actually knows how to play the game, guys.
What is she fucking doing?
Where is the healer?
Hello.
All I can fucking do is...
Right here.
Where are you not healing?
Right there.
You know what?
I'm gonna go get you.
Please.
I'm fucking...
Look at my HP.
I'm barely alive.
There she is again.
Maybe try stabbing her with a syringe.
Bro, I'm fucking free.
Free.
Just free the shit.
Ow.
Oh my God.
Guys, I'm dead.
There's so much.
Holy shit.
Okay, here.
Here.
Okay, guys.
Let's just find the armor door.
You're gonna heal things, right?
No, it's only... I think you do but you have to pick find it.
Okay, we gotta like... we gotta go to the basement.
Guys, wait, are you actually healing?
No, no.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We gotta find the basement.
I'm fucking... I'm gonna heal myself.
I don't need you guys anymore.
I wanna heal myself.
We just gotta find the bandages.
We gotta like go to the basement.
I don't know... what the fuck?
Go away!
Stop touching!
What the fuck are you doing to just touch that beside me?
We found the basement!
I found the basement!
The basement!
Oh, please stop!
Oh my god, not again.
Please!
That's too much!
I can't see anything!
Oh, there she is.
Don't worry, I'm zapping her!
I'm zapping her!
Be gone!
Oh my god, she fucking crossed.
AHHHH!
Oh shit.
Where's the light breaker?
Go away, Pring!
Pring, go away!
Where the fuck is the light breaker?
Where's the light?
Can I open your eyes?
I don't... I found it!
I found it!
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
I found it.
We gotta go downstairs!
I found the light breaker!
Where are you?
Let's go downstairs.
Okay, this has to be her.
Can you guys believe this is how much fun we had at the flashbang?
That's her, by the way.
Hey, thanks, Pring!
Thanks!
Hey, Pring, thanks for taking us to the basement, Pring!
We really appreciate it.
See, she read the tutorial!
Oh my god, she's got...
She fucking killed it!
She was trying to take us to the...
I can hear her!
No way!
She was trying to take us to the...
She was trying to take us to the thing!
Oh, here it is.
I found it.
Wait, we don't have the hooking tool.
Who has it?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's your turn.
Go to her.
I don't even know what it looks like.
No, she has it.
She has to do... I don't know how I did it.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
Use your cooldowns, Priest!
What the fuck is this?
Make sure we don't get...
We don't get... Are you okay?
What?
Okay, give me the hooking tool.
Give me the fucking hooking tool!
We can't protect you forever!
Oh, she did it!
Oh, it's my turn!
My turn!
Watch!
Nice, nice, nice!
How did you do this?
I don't fucking know, shit.
Just blast him?
Okay, I'm gonna keep blasting.
Pum!
This would work eventually, right?
This... Pum!
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
Don't worry!
Just protect me!
I'll do my job!
I'm literally 1 HP!
I don't have a lot of cooldowns!
I swear to god!
Get away!
We're doing our job, Priest!
Okay, I got here.
Alright, just protect me.
Just protect me while I do my actual job.
Hey.
Heya.
Give me a sec.
We have a lot of cooldowns here.
Be gone!
Oh my god.
I can't fucking...
Be gone!
Is this kinky or something?
Ew.
Am I doing it?
How long did it take you?
No, no, no.
You're doing it.
How long did it take you?
Oh my god!
We gotta hide!
You fucker.
Oh.
There's no way she knows we're here, right?
There's no way!
Oh.
Shut the fuck up!
Guy!
She can't hear us!
Oh my god.
Bro, she can't hear us!
Why are you fucking...
Why are you talking?
Why is she talking, bro?
She knew I was in the fucking closet.
I'm like, girl, I'm not coming out.
Where is she?
Where are you?
Where did you die?
Why?
Dude, she literally died.
She died.
I think she died real.
She was right in front of the closet.
Wait, she just died?
She was right in front of me.
Really?
She was like, come here, puta.
Oh shit!
Oh shit.
I'm trying to exorcise this guy.
Come here, come here, come here.
Oh no.
She's almost dead.
Okay, okay, okay.
These spirits are almost dead.
It's almost dead.
I'm trying so hard.
I'm blowing him away.
There we go.
I did it.
What the fuck?
Yeah, we did it.
Okay.
This is a little awkward that...
Is she actually dead?
Dead for real?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think she's...
You can die for real?
I thought it was just...
Yeah, I didn't know.
I was waiting.
You can die for real?
I feel kind of bad, but also, she deserves it, so it's fine.
Find the key that...
Oh, wait, these are new quests.
How do we get out of here?
I'm okay.
I'm not okay.
Oh my god!
You can do that this entire time?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kai, you have to pick me up.
Kai, please.
Kai, we need a key.
Oh my god, you're right.
13 seconds to be restored.
Oh my god.
There is a limit.
Keep praying.
Oh, who the fuck are the bats?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Sorry, I got the wrong one.
There were bats.
There's so many things going on.
We gotta leave.
We gotta leave this place.
This place is bad.
Why the fuck does she get this?
This map is...
Why the fuck?
Why couldn't you do this, Judah?
Hold on.
Wait, Bree, hold on.
Yeah, hold on.
Okay, now you can pick me up.
Get away.
Oh, you're nasty.
Oh, shit!
Guys, you have to keep me up.
No!
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
What the fuck?
I'm sorry, Judah.
I read the tutorial!
You're so good at this game!
I think she's gonna get the tutorial!
She actually cracked.
I read the tutorial!
Judah, why the fuck were you talking to me?
If you wait, it'll like give you...
It'll just stay in the lobby.
Okay, I'll be the demon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You'll be the demon.
I'll be the demon.
I have one target.
It's free, right?
Free, free, what are you gonna pick free?
I'm curious.
I'll go back to my medic.
It's okay.
I know what to do now.
Wait, wait, Kai, weren't you the priest last time?
Yeah, I was.
Yes.
You don't wanna be priest?
You're the priest!
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Alright, you.
Bye, goodbye.
GG's, good luck.
Alright, I'm in.
Oh, I have to possess an em- Oh, am I on a farm?
Wait, is this the same?
Is this the mansion again?
Why the fuck did they get the mansion?
Wait, no, this is a farmhouse.
Wait, is this a different?
No, this is...
Different?
Same?
I can't tell!
Oh, I'm gonna be you.
I'm gonna be you.
I'm gonna be a nice old lady.
That's fucking right.
Now what do I do?
Ha ha ha!
If I keep walking, they won't know.
They won't know.
They're gonna start off inside.
Oh my god, no, this is different.
I've never seen this place before.
Okay.
I didn't read the tutorial, so...
Good luck to me!
How do I get to the entrance?
Oh my god, I'm lost!
Wait, where am I?
Bob, regain life with demonic.
I'm turning the bell.
Oh.
I hear them.
There's a bitch in there.
Yeah, I saw her running.
What the fuck?
Sorry.
Get your ass over here, bitch.
And they have...
Sorry,
bro.
He just walks off.
Like, why do they stay here if they know it's possessed?
I know, right?
They have nowhere else to live.
Oh shit.
That was frightening.
Is that her?
She went upstairs.
Yeah.
Hello?
What the fuck?
I don't know.
She went upstairs.
Okay, okay.
Shut up!
Over.
Fuck!
What the fuck?
How did you get in there?
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Why can't we be friends?
It'll be alright.
What the fuck are you doing?
Wait, what the...
Oh, fuck.
Lightbox, lightbox, lightbox.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did it, I did it, I did it.
Why can't we be friends?
Oh shit, no!
My door!
Don't worry, I can crawl!
You can't fucking hit me!
Don't hit me!
That's a great...
You can't fucking get me!
I'm crawling away!
I can't see!
Oh my god!
What the hell?
What the fuck?
What did you do?
Ow!
Get off my fucking back!
What did you say about me not being a good monster?
Do you think it's fucking...
That's fucking right.
Give me like three seconds.
Give me three seconds!
No!
Shit!
Give me three seconds so I can do this.
No, no, no!
No fucking way!
It's okay, we're fine.
You think if I stay, don't keep her in the mirror three times, she'll appear behind me?
Hey!
What the fuck?
Bro, what the fuck?
Get away from me!
What the fuck was that?
Where are the altars?
How the fuck am I gonna be healed?
Oh my god, guys, I'm pretty fucked up right now.
What?
Get away!
Oh, I missed.
Guys, I missed.
Don't worry.
Get away!
Oh my god, cringe?
Don't worry.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
Get away from me!
I need a cooldown!
Okay.
That's right.
You don't know what to do.
That's fucking right.
That's a- I have the high ground now!
Wait, Kai, you're almost dead.
I think Kai's dying.
I think Kai's almost dead.
Kai!
Hey!
No!
That's fine.
I got him.
That's fucking right!
Oh!
Yes!
Oh,
come here.
Goodbye.
Where did I go?
That's the wrong person.
That's fucking right!
Oh my god!
What do you do about that?
Nothing!
No, I'm not.
No, I'm not!
Oh my god.
You don't know where I am!
Get out of here!
Down!
He feels low!
Wait, guys.
I don't know how to get down.
Get out of here!
Get away!
Get away from me!
Leave me alone!
I'm just an old lady!
That's so fucked up!
Oh no, we gotta find...
We gotta light the hall first.
Okay, here you go.
There you go.
This is so fucked up, guys.
Oh, she's healing!
What the fuck?
Her ass cracked?
Oh my god!
Bro, fuck you!
I hate it!
Oh shit!
Fuck you!
Fuck you guys!
That's fucking right.
Oh shit, my bad!
Well, I no longer have to...
That's right, you guys deserve that!
Oh my god!
That's fucking right!
Fuck you!
No!
That dude just...
There you go.
Okay.
We need a health item.
Medic, where's your medic?
Goodbye, sis.
I'm already...
Where the fuck is the heal?
How many times I have to teach you a lesson?
That's so fucked up that you guys won't...
It's so fucked up you guys will bully the elderly.
It's so fucked up.
That's so fucked up, guys.
You guys are trying to kill us!
Oh my god!
Old people built this city!
That's so fucked up!
They smell weird.
They're so gross.
Sometimes they try to kill us.
Wow!
That's fucked up.
Oh, we're fucked.
That's fucked up, guys.
I'm learning, I'm learning, I'm learning!
That's fucking right!
Yes!
No!
Get away!
Get over.
I got you, I got you.
No, you don't.
That's fucked up!
You're capping the heals.
I can't heal because you're literally capping.
You're literally capping heals.
Get out of the way.
I'm so f***ed up!
How am I supposed to hear?!
Bro, get off the f***ing heels!
Yeah.
That's f***ing...
That's f***ing right I am!
Let me in!
YES!
That's f***ing right!
I'mma camp you!
Nooo!
Don't do this!
This is so gross!
Nobody will save your life now!
No!
That's f***ing right!
No one can save you now!
That's f***ing right.
You die now.
Oh, you wanna crawl back?
That's right.
You wanna try crawling back?
I'm coming, Kai!
Don't worry!
I'm coming!
No!
Nobody's gonna save you!
I'm gonna try to get out of this house!
I'm coming!
No one...
Every time you pick me up, it resets my counter and so we're just gonna be here for a while.
Okay, don't worry.
I can wait.
Oh, dang it.
Thanks.
We can wait here.
Don't worry.
Weeeee!
Yuna!
Heeeeey!
Help!
And there she goes!
She's gone!
She's gone forever!
I'm so glad you're not laughing!
Bree's never coming back, guys!
She's never coming back!
Holy shit, your feet are looking rough!
Holy shit!
Dude, your toes!
Yum yum!
She's not coming back for you!
Yum yum yum!
She hit your nails done!
I think red would look really good on your toenails.
I figured out the game!
Where are you?
Oh, I should heal.
Actually.
What the fuck?
There's nothing here!
Oh, it's right here.
Alright.
Yuna!
Yuna, say something, Yuna!
You're the last one!
Yuna!
Oh my god, there's so many!
Open a portal?
Wait, what's this?
Turn invisible?
Let's do it.
Oh, Yuna!
Yuna!
You're gonna do the silence?
The silent run?
Oh, no, she's downstairs.
I hear you, Yuna!
I hear you!
You're somewhere around.
Oh, Yuna!
Come on, Yuna!
Say something!
Yuna, keep talking!
I'm trying to find you!
Oh, full heal.
I'm gonna full heal.
She has to be here somewhere.
Where the fuck did she go?
What the fuck?
Where is she?
Oh my god, she's just trying to one-man clutch this.
I'll keep healing until I'm full HP.
Until I find her.
Check every closet?
Oh, you're right.
Let's check every closet.
No closet for you.
How do you...
What
the fuck?
Where am I?
Hello?
Get
over here!
Get over here!
Respect your elders!
Listen, listen, listen.
I'm outside now.
I'm coming for you.
Oh shit, that's...
I can't leave...
the fucking... fucking...
Bannister blocked me.
Juna?
Where did you go?
Juna, you fucking...
You gotta die eventually!
Your friends are all dead!
All your friends are dead!
Get over here!
I hear you!
All your friends are literally...
Are you in here?
Juna?
Get over here!
Juna, you're still alive!
That's fucking right!
I'm coming for you!
No, you can't!
That's fucking right!
Get batted!
Yeah!
Outside for like 10 minutes.
You tubing by yourself in the corner with your little camera?
You're like, how are you sitting inside?
How are you sitting outside?
I let you die!
You let Kai die!
Kai left me to die!
So it was only fair, please understand.
I did it for the end game!
You did it for your own selfish gains!
But you still died!
You ran out the building and never came back!
I just look up and I see you two on the fucking roof!
I'm like, what is going on?!
The fact that you let me kidnap Bri up on the roof and you guys couldn't do anything about it.
I was watching you were playing with her body!
I fell off the other side of the roof and you guys weren't there to- I was on the ground!
She's just taking pictures, she got the camera.
You guys saved her!
She literally fell off the roof and you just let her die!
No, but I thought she was dead already!
Every time you fall off the roof, it resets it!
So you get 30 seconds every time!
I was playing with my food and you still didn't save her!
That's so fucked up!
Ash messed up, yo!
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I'm honestly so surprised we lasted so long that first game now.
We're getting through these so quick!
What the fuck was going on?!
Yeah!
Oh shit!
I'm so sorry!
The first 20 minutes I was like, how do I attack?
Because I could just only crawl.
Oh yeah!
I was just crawling around!
I was like, where's Juno?
I was so confused.
It's okay.
Juno, you purposely let us go through all the objectives to see what it was like, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, of course.
Trust.
That's so generous.
I can't believe you guys bullied the elderly though.
That's so fucked up.
That elderly killed me.
The elderly dragged it to the break.
And then they're in front of me.
I only did that because you three ganged up on this sweet, old lady.
You guys surrounded me, it was self-defense.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys, the only one who hasn't played the demon.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
I'm scared!
I don't know why I'm scared.
I'm the demon!
We got this.
This will be fun.
I'm just ready.
I'm gonna mute now.
Goodbye!
Goodbye forever!
Okay.
Anyway.
Kill machine!
Okay, I'm grabbing everything.
There's like med kits!
Why did you not grab the med kit?!
There's literally first aid!
Okay.
I'm grabbing med kit.
Yeah!
There's a dog clicker!
Okay.
I don't think so.
These are only reserved for me.
You can?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I picked it up!
Oh, maybe it was like XP!
I have the XP!
When I was at med... Oh, what the fuck?
Because I think we got more XP now.
Because I played survivor, I can probably pick it up now too if I played the mimic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I have the med kit.
I can actually heal.
I can heal now.
You can actually do your med kit.
You finally got the proper license.
I have the license to heal.
Let me see.
What do my things do?
This has to be the demon.
The demon, right?
Who's this guy?
Oh, look at your dog!
Look at your dog!
Look at my doggie!
Where is he?
Where is she?
Come here, come here.
There's a doggie!
Oh my god!
What is that?
That's so cute!
Okay, he's patrolling.
He's doing his job.
Yeah, he's doing his job.
Alright, we gotta find me.
Wait, we got...
Why are you...
Oh, that was... Oh, no, that's an enchantment.
That means she was near because she enchanted.
Yeah.
Okay, so we gotta...
We gotta find Candace.
The demon gets closer.
Oh, really?
Wait, I heard her.
Wait, I hear...
Wait, wait, wait, I hear her.
I hear her.
I hear...
We hear you, Kai!
Kai, speak!
Oh, right here.
Right here.
That's fucking right!
Get away!
Yeah!
Leave!
Oh, wait!
Oh, mama!
Holy shit!
Yeah!
That's fucking right!
Stun locker!
That's good, Adalyn!
Yeah!
Oh, I kicked her out.
That's fucking right!
Believe her!
Oh, is she here?
No, she got...
She, like, teleported away.
Like, when you hit her too much.
Wait, we gotta find the candle.
Oh, my God!
Wait, the dog sits on this, like, this portal on the ground.
Oh!
There's just, like, this giant red portal that's blowing.
It's upstairs.
Wait, where's...
Where's Judah?
I'm trying to...
Judah, where are you doing?
What are you doing out here?
I was following her!
Get back inside!
We gotta do our mission!
I can climb walls!
Get inside before she drags you to the roof!
Get inside!
She can climb down!
Oh!
Bro, what the fuck?
Why did you...
I thought that was...
I just wanted to see if I could.
The possibility was there.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
Let's...
Oh, my gosh.
She's just a hospital.
Die.
We gotta find the candle.
Wait.
Oh!
Wait!
She was behind us!
Don't worry!
I have the med kit!
Here!
I dropped it.
Take it.
Thank you!
Yeah, we can heal now.
We can heal.
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I have night vision.
I took my night vision pill.
Oh, I have a...
I have a...
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Okay.
Get away!
I have a gun!
I missed.
Uh...
This one.
No.
Get away!
That's what I want.
Okay.
Come over here now!
Let me shoot you!
We need...
Oh!
She's invincible!
Oh, that's not good!
That's not good!
Leave!
We're sorry!
No!
It wasn't a joke!
We love the elderly!
We love the elderly so much!
No!
Please!
Wait, is it true?
Do you really love the elderly?
Yes, it was true.
I would never lie about that.
You know that.
I always...
No, please!
It wasn't a joke!
That was a joke!
Because I love the...
But I'm scared!
I'm scared!
I was so scared!
Guys!
Please!
I'm so scared!
Oh, she's okay!
She...
Oh, she's fine!
It's fine!
Okay.
Guys, we...
We're okay.
We're okay now.
We're fine!
We need to find a candle!
We haven't found anything yet.
Oh my God!
We haven't...
I'm healing myself.
I realize the first aid kit only gives you a plus 7.5.
Oh.
This is not good.
Oh my God!
Guys!
Oh!
Get away!
Oh my God!
Oh!
Get away!
Get her away!
Oh my God.
Guys, I'm not okay.
I'm not...
Sorry.
What the fuck?
It's okay.
Guys, we have to do something!
We've done nothing, guys!
We haven't found a single candle!
I got too much!
We haven't found anything!
Do you know where the stuff are?
Wait, where's Bri?
Where's Bri?
Bri!
Oh shit!
Yeah!
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, take a picture.
Oh, you look so cute!
Yeah, look at that!
It's so cute!
Wait, let's take a group photo!
Can we take a group photo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'll crouch down.
I'm really tall.
I'll crouch down.
Okay.
You are really tall.
Okay, hold on.
We gotta wait for the cooldown.
Alright, here you go.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
What does this do?
Cheese!
Hallelujah!
That's so fucked up!
Wait, why do I keep getting these cutscenes?
That's so fucked up.
That is so fucked up!
I'm literally killing you.
That's so fucked up!
I'm literally dead right now.
Get her away!
I'm literally gonna hit the Woody right now.
Picture!
Oh my god.
Guys!
You can't kill us if we keep pressing each other!
Can I grab?
Oh, I thought I could grab you.
We're fine.
Okay, she threw a thing at us.
Leave us alone!
We have to drop!
We're just so cute!
We're just having a nice little time!
This is so unfair!
Leave us alone!
We have to fucking make money for our families!
We're dead!
You don't have families!
There's a...
Wait, why do I keep getting...
Wait, how do I keep getting just the pitch?
You couldn't get that one!
She couldn't fucking...
She's stuck!
Look at her!
She's fucking stuck!
What a loser!
Look at her!
Wait, she's almost dead!
We can actually kill her!
We can actually kill her, guys!
Get back here!
We can kill you!
We know you have a weakness now!
No, she's almost dead!
We can kill her!
Get her down!
We're so bad!
Wait, she's over here.
I'm gonna fucking throw up!
Get out!
Get out of here!
I'm gonna fucking throw up!
This is right!
I'm so sorry!
Don't worry!
Why would you hurt me?
What is she doing?
I don't know.
I'm waiting for you to go anywhere.
We'll keep healing.
Ow!
Oh shit!
Can you help me?
I'm saving you!
Don't worry!
We can kill her!
She's about to murder!
She can't get away forever!
Get over here!
She went to the roof!
Get back inside!
She's in the roof!
She's gonna put you in the roof!
She's fucking figuring out our weakness.
The outside.
The moment we're inside, we're safe.
We're only safe when we're inside.
We haven't done anything.
We still have five more candles.
We need our five candles.
Where the fuck would the candles be?
We're here!
She's here!
She's on me!
I slowed her down!
Oh shit!
I need you guys to pick me up here!
Rescue me!
Hello!
Medic!
Oh wait!
What the fuck?
Medic!
We gotta heal each other!
The mo- we can- Oh fuck.
I'm okay.
Oh she's- oh that's a dog!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
No we're not!
She doesn't see me!
What the fuck bro?!
Can you get down?
Oh wait shit!
You're coming with me!
Get up!
Stop!
No!
You couldn't even get her out!
Oh wait I'm gonna- What the fuck?
Where did she go?
Oh there she is!
She's stuck!
Kill her!
She can't!
She can't fucking leave!
She's like one inch me!
She's literally one!
Get her ass!
She's one!
Oh fuck!
She's so dead!
We did it!
Wait!
That's fucking right!
You don't like my dark side?
What the fuck?
You- Alright.
Okay.
Well we know who's the worst demon out there.
I know!
We know who's the worst one out there.
I'm trying to figure out what the thing is!
I see what's hard cause!
It is!
It is hard!
Alright I won't shit on you again.
I'm sorry.
This is the last game I can get a redemption arc as a demon for our last game or something.
Alright.
Okay.
You got this.
Wait.
Wait wait.
Before you guys mute me.
Where should we go?
Like do you want a manor, hotel, house, or the asylum again?
Which one have we not done?
We should do the asylum.
Cause like we haven't gotten to actually do the asylum.
Doki?
The last one was the asylum.
I know!
Whichever one honestly.
Whichever one really.
Which one was the easiest?
For Jun- I think the one that I was in was fairly easy.
Oh the hotel?
Yeah yeah.
If it wasn't and it becomes hard that just makes my ego better though cause that means that I did well on it.
Okay.
I'll do my best.
Trust.
I believe in you.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna kill that kid.
I'm the priest now.
Alright I'm the engineer again.
We're back to the OGs.
We figure out how to play this time.
Alright muting.
Yup.
Alright.
I can finally heal.
Oh I still can't do the buff.
I wanna get the dove.
I can do stun, current gun I can do.
I can.
I can't grab anything.
What the fuck?
Oh someone doesn't have enough XP.
Oh wait I'm stupid.
Oh.
Okay I have armor.
Someone's in armor to defend all those inside it.
Dash.
Okay we're good.
We're good.
Okay I'm ready.
Spiritual burst.
Shockwave.
Orbs.
And I got spiritual burst.
I got telekinesis.
Can I?
Can I invest in it?
I got everything.
Alright.
Hello.
Did you get the dog clicker?
Were you able to get the dog?
Did you get the dog?
Dog clicker.
I don't know.
What does it look like?
It's in the middle here.
Yeah yeah.
It's right here.
Did you get it?
Oh yeah I did.
Oh my god we have the dog.
Okay guys.
We can do this.
We're gonna win.
We're so... Okay.
We can do this.
There's no way.
As long as we stick together we're fine.
Oh yeah I got the car.
We gotta find candles.
Where the fuck are the candles?
Okay easy.
Okay.
Oh I found one.
I found one.
I found two.
Wait wait wait.
What does it look like?
It's just a candle.
It's just like this.
Oh okay.
Oh!
Yeah yeah yeah.
Oh I see I see I see.
Okay we have... We need two more.
We need two more.
Alright.
Okay.
Use this right now.
I don't think we need armor right?
What does the magnetic detector do?
It senses a demon.
Wait.
Yeah.
Oh that's her!
That's her!
That's why she jumped!
NPCs can't jump!
I figured it out!
NPCs don't jump!
That's automatically her!
Oh my god.
You fucking fucking cunt!
Oh no she's actually... She can navigate!
Oh no!
Oh no she...
She knows how to crawl!
No she knows how to crawl!
What a freak!
What a literal fucking freak.
Freak!
This is why you got bullied and became a demon!
Okay we need a...
We need to find the...
We need to find one more candle.
Ooh doggie!
Wait.
I can actually do my task.
Oh my god.
Oh huge!
I'm doing it!
Oh my god huge!
She's finally learned.
We need to find another candle.
We're literally missing one candle.
Oh!
No that's bandage.
Where the fuck?
How about matches though?
We're literally missing one candle!
Oh no guys.
I split up with the gang.
This is not good.
Look this is important for the candle though.
Would there be candles upstairs?
There'd be candles upstairs.
Right?
Collect blood from crying statues?
Maybe there'd be candles upstairs.
Wait do we do it?
Am I stuck?
Guys!
Oh.
What?
Oh I was in the table.
I was like what the fuck?
Guys have you found the last candle yet?
What
the?
Is that?
Was that you?
Did you guys?
We did it!
It's me.
Yeah it's me.
I found like an enchanted.
One of the fucking more minions.
We need to find collect blood from crying Is that the statues outside?
Oh I'm lost.
Guys.
What do crying statues look like?
Guys?
Oh it must be outside right?
Chippy Chippy chop chop chop Oh
no!
Oh no!
Guys I found her.
I found the statues.
It's outside.
Oh.
Okay.
It's outside.
Get away!
Get away from us!
You're not wanted Judah!
Get away!
Nobody!
Nobody thinks you're cool!
We did it!
Place the candles.
Oh where's the circle?
Nah nah I'm good.
I'm good.
Alright I think we did it!
Place the candles in a circle and light them.
Where the fuck is that?
And where?
Yeah where?
We have a good reason not to fucking shoot you right now Judah.
Oh wait watch this.
That's fucking right you did it.
He's just gonna cry.
She's just a little child.
No!
She's a demon!
Demons don't deserve love!
She's so sweet.
She's so sad.
She's just manipulating you.
She's just acting.
It's just acting.
Don't be...
Don't be a little bitch.
Alright we gotta...
Alright guys we gotta find the circle.
Do you think it's in the basement?
I thought it'd be outside.
Or it could be.
Or maybe it's in the weird altar place.
It says like place the blood vial.
We gotta find...
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh!
Why were you looking at this poor man?
Bro!
What did you do to this poor guy?
Bro what the fuck?
What is wrong with you?
Alright maybe downstairs.
It could be downstairs.
You think?
Yeah yeah.
It has to be downstairs.
Wait where's Bree?
I'm gonna try and keep her.
I'm gonna go downstairs.
Bree?
Bree will be fine right?
Oh well she'll be fine.
Yeah she's full HP.
There's no way.
Yeah she's got all those vices.
Yeah yeah.
And all those syringes.
Yeah I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
Oh what the fuck you...
Oh you knew it.
Alright she knew it too.
Apparently.
June is coming.
I'm so confused.
I don't know how they...
She's so confused.
Oh not the lights.
We gotta figure out the lights.
Oh there's a circuit breaker right here.
Oh nice.
Dude this is like the thing I'm best at.
Just keep fixing it.
When you have five sets of electric...
That's your old job!
You literally got a degree for this.
I'm literally Doki.
Yeah?
Let me show you my license.
Here you go.
Nice.
Finally.
It took her 20 years to get her medical degree.
We gotta find...
electric cables.
Where would that be?
I've never seen what it looks like either.
Maybe out...
Oh!
We found the generator.
Yeah yeah.
Yeah I'm gonna go upstairs and see.
Oh here's another one.
Oh we found two generators.
What would the electric cable look like?
Yeah.
What would the cables look like?
I don't know.
We got the generators.
I got more matches.
I'm right here behind you.
Juna!
Where are you Juna?
Juna you're not beating the allegations about you and your skills in monsters.
I don't like this.
Oh that's you.
That was on reflex.
Juna!
Where the fuck?
Where is the electric cable?
I don't know what they look like.
I don't know either.
Oh this has to be something.
Oh we put a generator here.
That's our goal.
We have to go here.
Maybe downstairs?
Maybe go back in basement?
Maybe.
Where the fuck did Juna go?
Juna!
Juna get back here Juna!
Everybody always possesses the elderly.
Juna we know you're on the roof.
Get down!
Juna we know... No she's back.
Oh no she's literally right here.
Juna get back here Juna!
Juna!
I'm just a baby.
You were laughing at the dog.
It's perfect.
Holy shit.
I'm not letting you swim in my little ear.
Unless you wanna be my next fucking meal.
Oh I found it!
I found it!
It's just on the floor.
It's just like wires on the floor.
Oh oh oh okay.
Okay okay.
Just look on the floor.
No!
Why the fuck did you do this to this poor man?
Damn Juna.
Juna!
Juna this is not looking good for you.
That'll be five dollars.
Alright.
Five dollars?
Is that him?
What the fuck?
That's not Juna.
That can't be Juna.
No it's just a man.
Oh yeah it's just a man.
Just a man.
Oh shit.
The demon has turned it off.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck?
Oh there's another generator.
Find the incantation table.
Oh hey.
Hey what are you doing?
No no no no no.
I have a family.
You're right!
I'm sorry!
You're having family!
Please!
Please don't!
I also have a family!
Please!
What happened to family?
I don't understand!
I've been nothing but kind!
What?
Oh!
Nice!
Okay.
Okay we're okay.
We're okay now.
We're okay.
Oh my god.
How do I get back inside?
We're okay now.
I'm restoring the power.
I hope that's like...
Oh nice.
Bro this electrical...
This electric cable shit is so difficult!
Are you guys okay?
Bro where the fuck is the electrical cable?
I found it!
Guys I found it!
Go to the table!
Guys!
I found it!
Go to the table!
Why is this so hard?
Why do I do it?
It's so hard!
Junet!
Just stop being a little girl!
Oh my god!
Okay I'm here!
I found it!
We go to the table!
We go!
We go outside!
Oh my god!
Bro!
Oh my god it actually worked for the first time ever!
It worked for the stupid anti-invisibility thing!
It worked!
Get the fuck out of here!
Get out of here!
Nobody!
Where did she get up with ugly ass fucking stupid bitch?
It's cause I had armor bitch!
Oh guys guys we gotta like not let her just do that to us.
Let's just go to the table.
Guys let's just go.
Guys where the fuck I left?
I left.
I know what the objective is.
Where the fuck?
Where is it?
Whoa!
Oh.
Hey.
Okay so she's right behind me.
She's right behind me.
Yeah!
Hey!
Finding the table!
Woo!
Where the fuck is the table?
Oh I found it.
Nice.
Objective time.
Oh no.
Okay.
There we go.
And then...
Am I...
Is this correct?
No.
No that was not correct.
Okay.
Sorry they're distracting...
They're distracting Juna for me while I figure this out.
There we go.
And then we're just gonna keep turning until this hits.
Yeah!
I did it!
Oh no am I bugged forever?
Collect electric...
Oh no I bugged myself.
Oh no.
Oh.
Did I bug myself?
No I didn't.
Oh no I can't run.
No.
I can't run.
Guys!
Oh no.
Wait!
How did they all die?
What did you do Juna?
What did you do?
What happened?
What do you mean?
How the fuck did they all die?
I was doing a puzzle!
Okay tell me how you got the...
Get away!
You wanna talk about it?
I don't want it!
No!
I don't want to talk about it!
I can't...
How the fuck did you guys die?
I was doing a puzzle!
Juna you're too good at this!
What happened?
We were doing a puzzle.
I just saw you and then we both went down.
And I turned back to ask for help.
And you just disappeared.
I thought you were okay.
I was trying to... Oh no.
I was trying to...
I was like oh they'll be fine.
I'm gonna do this puzzle and then...
No!
No we weren't!
You were not fine.
I was a little bad in the beginning but...
Yeah you were natural.
It makes sense.
Redemption arc.
The Juna redemption arc right there.
I went from 40 minutes to 14.
That was so good.
The evil laughing throughout really sucked.
I know right?
I just hear her fucking devilish laughing.
That was great.
I was like we do this.
I know.
Holy shit.
You didn't mean to purposely leave them though right?
No I was like it'll be fine.
I'm gonna do the fucking puzzle.
Yeah you purposely left us.
You purposely left us.
It'll be fine.
I'm gonna do the puzzle.
They're gonna protect me from the puzzle.
No.
I'm sorry.
I learned things off my shoes.
I'm sorry you relied on the wrong people.
I'm sorry.
I realized that was a mistake.
I was the medic and I was always the first one going into a shooter.
I had one gun and it was Elisa Rage.
I was like oh maybe I shouldn't have left.
Oh yeah you think?
I'm so glad that crossed your mind.
Yeah.
It's like you.
Definitely shouldn't have left.
It's okay.
That was fun.
That was awesome.
This is why we had to go in blind without the tutorial.
I'm sorry.
It's better.
It's better because the demon is so overpowered when you figure out how to actually play the demon.
I was like when I played and the first thing I heard was oh my god she knows how to play the game.
Oh no.
I was like oh no.
We're not gonna have a good time.
She knows how to play.
It's okay.
But I guess I actually have nothing else to say.
The demons we made along the way.
The people we killed along the way.
The new appreciation for elderly women.
We're so nimble.
Oh my god.
Children and the elderly.
Who would have thought.
I feel like I just did something unethical.
I gotta go to the nursing home and bring them cupcakes.
I gotta do some community service now.
I feel like I'm morally obligated right now.
They deserve it.
They're coaching.
The next elderly could be the next demon.
You'll never know.
Remember, treat your elders right or else they might kill you.
Yeah, exactly.
This is why we put them in homes.
Because we're worried about them turning into demons.
They'll just turn into demons between each other.
Retirement homes are actually like homes for demons.
Churches.
Yeah.
Abuela, no.
Abuela.
We gotta be safe.
Do any of you guys have announcements?
For like the coming week?
It's just a physical lab.
I mean like it's like I normally just ask and then they're like, wow that's so cool you're so slay.
I mean be nice again.
You need to be nice.
She's like nice?
What?
What are you doing?
That has to be a genius right?
Nobody's nice for no reason.
What do you mean?
I always ask this question.
It's true.
She does.
I'm like, Kai, do you have anything upcoming?
And she goes, yeah I'm gonna do this and that.
I'm like, oh wow that's so nice.
That's exactly what the words are that she says every time.
That's exactly how I sound.
I'm like, oh my god.
Baby, are you the baby Kai?
Oh my god, the baby.
Yeah.
I feel like we had role play session.
We were doing it before the collab as well by the way.
I think I walked into some role play shit.
It's like a VR chat where you join a random world and then there's these two people around.
It's okay Jenna, she doesn't understand this.
She doesn't understand our bond, our relationship.
No.
It's just like.
I like it, you know, like doing it in public like this PDA.
Is this a part of it?
Is this part of it?
No, this is part of it.
Are you part of it to do it in public?
So like people would watch?
No, bro, that's when everything's out.
We're still covered, bro.
So now?
We're still covered.
We have like, we have space for Jesus too.
Also the baby.
Are you the baby?
Is this an exhibition?
Yes, this is...
It's not exhibition because there's no private parts to key.
We're still clothed.
Jesus.
Amen.
Now we know who's definitely going to hell.
She learned something from the demons.
We know gates are closed for someone here.
That was fun.
Thank you.
Thank you for inviting Kai and Bri.
Thank you for inviting me.
Thank you for joining me.
For playing this game with me.
I was going to try this game out.
So thank you guys.
I hope that was fun.
We had a lot of fun murdering people.
Yeah, I had a great time.
I agree.
GG guys.
I'm going to go talk to my chat now.
Bye guys.
Bye.
That was so fun.
I think that was really, really fun guys.
It was great meeting them for the first time.
I've never talked to them before.
I talked to Juna before.
She actually went to one of my meet and greets a long time ago.
I think I told this story before.
Obviously there's no vibes of it anymore.
Juna was actually one of the I think the only Vtuber that came to my meet and greet and purposely requested to meet me during one of my meet and greets.
And he brought her fucking screen over to talk to me and everything.
And I know I'm her Oshi so I was like I'll ask her if she wants to meet me.
I'll ask her if she wants to do a collab with me.
Because I remember that I was one of her Oshis.
And I said you can invite anybody to join us.
Because I really want to play this game anyway.
So I was like you know what?
I'll ask her if she wants to play.
And I had a great time.
I had a great time playing with Juna, Kai, and Bri.
They were really fun.
You know what Bri's voice reminds me of?
Bri's voice reminds me of Remember when I was showing you guys that song above from Garfunkel?
Like what's her name?
Her voice fucking reminds me like literally was like almost exactly like that.
Oh my god what was her voice?
It was literally almost me, you, and Steve.
Yeah I was like oh my god her voice is literally just like her voice.
It was like Kate Micucci.
That's her name right?
Yeah she sounds just like Kate Micucci.
No joke.
Like literally one to one.
Because like Kate Micucci was the voice of um the ducktales.
What was her name?
Ducktales.
The girl in Ducktales.
The little girl.
Uh fuck what was her name?
Ah what was that little girl's name in Ducktales?
Uh...
You know what I'm talking about?
Like...
What was that name?
Uh...
That little girl in Ducktales!
Oh my gosh girl.
I'm just gonna google...
Webby!
She sounds just like Webby!
Doesn't she?
I was like oh my god that's literally Webby's voice!
Because like um Kate Micucci like has like the same the same like uh she does like a lot of voice acting for TV shows and like she literally sounds like her.
.
Who does?
Uh Brie!
Brie!
Brie literally sounds like Webby from Ducktales.
I was like I was like trying to remember I was like oh my gosh this is like one to one exactly her voice.
.
I was like holy shit that's literally her.
Like how like people are like oh my god Doki you sound like that fucking girl in Gravity Falls.
Even though I don't think so.
I don't think I sound like her.
I think like I would sometimes hit the intonations of her but like I don't think I I personally don't think I actually sound like her.
Like what's her name?
I keep forgetting but like the girl who's that main character.
Mabel.
Yeah sometimes apparently sometimes I can sound like Mabel when I talk but I don't I don't hear it.
But I think if I go higher I think if I go a higher pitch I sound like Mabel.
Um .
Yeah.
So but I swear Brie sounds exactly like Webby from DuckTales and she sounds like cause like the actress does like so many voice acting where like different uh uh well Velma!
It's like a mix between Velma and Webby.
It sounds just like it sounds like almost like Velma and Webby if you think about it.
Like if you just listen to it.
And I was like oh my god every time she opens her mouth I was like oh my god I feel like I feel like that's just Velma and Webby.
It's so cool.
It's so cool I was like it's such a unique voice.
Um it's like a really unique voice too.
So I was like that's really cool.
Um anyway I had a great time.
I had a great time meeting them.
It was really really fun.
Um playing with the girls and yeah I'm like really tired so I'm gonna rest a little bit.
We do have one more stream.
We do have one more stream today.
Uh which is like Goodnight Dragoons.
Uh so uh so uh I'm gonna rest now and then we're gonna hang out later tonight cause my brain is like fried at the moment cause I can't talk anymore.
My brain is my brain is fried at the moment so like I can't verbalize anything anymore.
So I'll see you guys at the next stream everybody.
As always everybody uh stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Mmm bye!